n'empêche qu'on ait des métiers utiles
et on doit marcher main dans la main
parce que la réforme des retraites elle
nous démolit tous elle démolit tous les
salariés du pays le fait qu'on
n'augmente pas les salaires massivement
des profs des soignants des flics est
une catastrophe parce que ça fait que
les gens ne veulent plus faire ces
métiers les gens ne veulent plus être
prof aujourd'hui les gens ne veulent
plus être flics les gens ne veulent plus
être soignants les conditions de travail
sont extrêmement dégradées
côté discipline faut imaginer écouter
salaire ça compte l'argent c'est pas on
fait pas ce métier pour l'argent mais
c'est pas une raison mais c'est pas une
raison pour être souper il y a un moment
où il faut être logique un pays doit
respecter les services publics tout
bêtement alors Nicolas merci on a
Perrine qui est à côté de nous qui est
fan de policier ce soir vous allez
représenter votre mari plus globalement
les familles des forces de l'or votre
mari il est actuellement sur le terrain
oui il est il est engagé sur le terrain
alors lui il est plutôt en bac mais il y
a certaines bacs qui ont été engagés
effectivement sur les manifestations
pour prêter main forte aux effectifs
interpellant donc il a quand il rentre
en ce moment il vous dit quoi
pas que la situation allait réintante
elle est dramatique on a des rappels de
nos hommes et nos femmes pour pouvoir
assurer ces manifestations là faut se
dire que on est au bout de six jours de
manifestations sauvages qui se
transforment en attroupement et qui se
transforme souvent en violence urbaine
avec des tirs d'engins incendiaires de
cocktail Molotov des jets de de mortiers
d'artifice des jets de pavés on a vu une
policière et s'écrouler littéralement
sous un pavé malgré les protections
c'est une violence inouïe il y a
certains incendies qui maintenant se
propage même à des immeubles
d'habitation hier soir la DOPC donc la
direction d'ordre public et la
circulation
laissez effectifs ont mis en sécurité
plus de 20 personnes à la suite d'un
incendie parce que ils se sont propagés
parce qu'il y avait des incendies de
poubelles etc aujourd'hui c'est
énormément de d'heures de fait en ce
moment on a une compagnie de CRS qui a
fait plus de 24 heures d'engagement 24
c'est énorme elles sont plus violentes
que les autres les manifestations pour
votre façon de plus en plus violentes on
a connu les gilets jaunes moi j'aime mon
compagnon a été à ce moment là sur les
manifestations et on avait déjà assisté
à un accroissement de la violence à un
accroissement des menaces même hors du
travail parce que maintenant un fixe ça
se fait suivre ça se fait comme on dit
vulgairement détromphés quand il rentre
chez lui c'est des menaces sur nos
familles c'est des menaces sur moi-même
sur ce sont des injures quotidiennes et
aujourd'hui oui c'est de plus en plus
non
vous avez peur quand il part évidemment
que j'ai peur quand il part évidemment
que j'ai peur quand il part parce qu'on
en est même pas sûr qu'il va pouvoir
rentrer entier vous avez plus de 394
policiers qui ont été blessés sur ces
manifestations comment ne pas avoir peur
et ce qui vous dit quand
est-ce qu'il est angoissé ce qu'il dit
j'ai envie d'arrêter ce travail ce qui
lui est passé par la tête d'arrêter un
moment
ça traverse parfois l'idée mais les
valeurs qui ont poussé à s'engager dans
la police nationale elle demeure est-ce
qu'il est d'accord avec les manifestants
la majorité des de la population est
d'accord avec les manifestants la
majorité de la population
l'ordre mais il est quand même s'il
avait été c'est à dire que si il avait
fait un autre métier serait descendu
dans la rue mais en fait les policiers
sont descendus dans la rue les syndicats
ont manifesté dès les premiers jours de
manifestations contre cette réforme des
retraites il y a 70% de la population
les policiers font partie de ces 70% de
la population qui sont contre cette
réforme des retraites évidemment